papa c'est mon petit ami Martin plaisir
de vous rencontrer mr.  Gallow a l'air familier
Martin certain est un musicien le banjo
comme Kermit the Frog gal Ginny home
Broadcom toute idée d'où je pourrais la trouver
Je n'ai pas d'adresse mais j'ai
été là-bas tu veux t'habiller et
tu peux m'emmener  là tu sais
où on va tu conduis Oh en fait
je ne conduis pas la roue du changement mais certains
d'entre nous ont adoré son petit toot quoi
remplissons la maison de mère
pourquoi pas c'est le turbo ok nous devrions
y aller hé je peux venir
je pense qu'elle  j'ai des enfants après toi, alors qu'est
-ce que tu fais exactement,
nous avions l'habitude de plaisanter en disant que tu es un
marchand d'armes, je suis dans les achats
[
Applaudissements]  Gao comment peux-tu m'appeler gratuitement Je ne
pense pas que je puisse faire ça
c'est très mauvais J'ai besoin de voir si ma
fille a des problèmes ce que nous avons
cherché Ginny toute la journée et toute la
nuit à fuir la police n'a vraiment pas
besoin  un récapitulatif d'accord j'y étais
cela se produit tous les jours c'est comme un film
John Wayne juste quel film c'est la
vie cela vous dérangerait-il de simplement mettre
en place dedans ce que nous ne sommes pas
tombés notre vieil homme effrayant jeune homme fouetter
Tague hashtag aléatoire faisable